you're kidding yourself if you think our
long
national electoral nightmare will be
over on november 3rd
and not just because it might take days
or even
weeks before we know who won if donald
trump wins
anti-immigration anti-abortion and
protectionist republicans will continue
pushing their mostly unpopular agenda in
washington
if joe biden wins as most observers
expect
anti-capitalist anti-school choice and
pro-regulation progressives will pass
legislation
similarly out of sync with america's
more centrist electorate but whoever
wins
there's a good chance that power will
flip to the other side in two years or
four
that's because we're living in an era of
unstable majorities according to
stanford political scientist morris p
fiorina for the past 20 years control of
congress
and the white house has regularly jumped
back and forth between
increasingly extreme wings of both
parties this kind of chaotic electoral
environment we hadn't seen since the
late 19th century a period they called
the period of no decision
in 2018 the democrats took the house
back
in 2020 it seems very likely they'll
take the presidency back
possibly the senate as well so this era
of electoral chaos
of flopping majorities i call it
continues as far as i can see
until the 1980s says fiorina both
parties resembled each other more than
they differed
it wasn't the end of the world for most
people the other party won but
since the reagan era republicans and
democrats have sorted almost completely
into ideologically conservative and
liberal groups
raising the stakes of each election even
as fewer people
identify with either major party each
party wants to impose
its particular platform progresses on
the democratic side the
various conservatives on the republican
side and the country is ready for that
there's going to be demands for buying
to act strongly on climate change
and there's going to be people unhappy
if he doesn't embrace much of the green
new deal i mean just pick your issue
he's not giving enough attention to race
he's not giving
attention to this it's just really not a
good time to be a president
most americans agree with each other on
issues ranging from abortion to
immigration
to gay marriage to free trade but they
can't express that agreement
at the voting booth i don't think we're
on the verge of civil war
i think that the fever swamps of our
newsrooms and
social media are just not reflective of
the mood out there in general
i think a lot of people wish for
something better but don't really see it
out there on the part of either party
you know if you go back and look at the
60s if you look at the destruction
and you look at the loss of lies and the
violence we somehow muddled through it
so i think we will probably as a country
do it again although it won't be pretty
and we'll be quick